last meet the media hyped yesterday's
unite the right to March a white
supremacist gathering in Washington a
large gathering of white supremacists in
the nation's capital who will march for
the same apparent reason that they
marched on that day a year ago from
Sunday white nationalists and bigots
like the ones you're seeing on your
screen from a year ago are expected to
once again take to the streets this time
in front of the White House as the White
House pushes back on her allegations
that the president is a racist thousands
of white Nationals are preparing to
demonstrate just outside the White House
this weekend did he say thousands well
despite all that the supremacist managed
to turn out a whopping 20 protestors
they were far outnumbered by the members
of the press whose news organizations
undoubtedly spent gobs of dough giving
them free airtime to the pathetic
largely irrelevant band of racially
obsessed
Malkin tents so have the media ever
given this much pregame publicity to a
March that actually turns out I don't
know hundreds of thousands of protesters
most of them young they often show up in
bitter cold or freezing rain you know
like the annual March for Life I don't
think so
but that annual event is positive and
life-affirming and respectful and
attended as I said by mostly high school
college kids and it does not advance the
left's agenda but the weekends white
supremacist circus had possibilities the
president rightly tweeted before the
much-ballyhooed supremacist march in
washington the following he said the
riots in Charlottesville a year ago
resulted in senseless death and division
we must come together as a nation he
wrote that he condemned all types of
racism and acts of violence and he said
peace to all Americans
well since Trump wrote down that shiny
escalator to announce his candidacy
journalists have worked overtime to
paint him as an avowed racist well every
view he has for instance on law
enforcement standing for the national
anthem
the travel ban and of course on
immigration they all allege it's
racially motivated it can't possibly be
that the president advances policies and
ideas because he believes it's going to
be good for Americans good for safety
good for the American worker now well
you add the tragic events of
Charlottesville a year ago and you had
the media's backdrop going into this
weekend's unite the right freak show
those sad 20 figures were swamped by
over a thousand counter protesters and
some did carry signs that simply read
kindness or love and that was heartening
but the real fireworks happened when
these folks showed up
[Music]
[Applause]
it was basically a family affair
well black lives matter and you know and
the domestic terrorist posing as
protesters aka auntie feh were present
and revealing the ugly underbelly of
what could have been a powerful
statement against true hate instead
here's how CNN though classified all the
non white supremacist as quote anti hate
groups huh I don't know about you but
just like we all know what the vile
hatred of racist sounds like we should
all know what it sounds like when
directed at a racially diverse police
force who are standing there either in
the heat or in the rain just trying to
do their job on Sunday they wanted to
get it where the 20 racial obsessed mild
contents were well apparently protesters
like to tear each other limb from limb
and want the police to get out of the
way and if you happen to be driving a
vehicle in the vicinity yesterday this
is black lives matters way of spreading
love and peace
[Applause]
[Music]
now if these guys have nothing to hide
and they're on the side of right anyone
asks them why they're wearing masks to
conceal their identity from law
enforcement you know why because they
destroy property they harass officers
throw projectiles at them and they just
attack the innocent now at this next
video this couples crime
well wearing trunk t-shirts
[Music]
still the media coddle antifa and these
leftist protesters largely because their
anti-trump message aligns with the one
prevailing in a lot of American
newsrooms but if they're going to cover
for them rather than cover them well the
media now aligned themselves with this
message too
[Applause]
at least the rhyming not that you'll see
or hear many of those images on other
media of course not even when these
lunatics by the way turn on journalists
attacking reporters in the street
cutting their cords to their cameras as
they did this weekend the media just
they want to look the other way we shove
it on people what's wrong with you
clever well this was posted by an NBC
reporter on his Twitter account it shows
his camera crew assaulted by these
nutjobs yet later when NBC went to
coverage of the event with the same
reporter they omitted the fact that
their own crew had been assaulted and
they showed no video of the incident huh
how curious imagine if Majid if some
conservative group oriented had done
that to a reporter what they would have
said they get upset when the Trump crowd
screams a cost to go home well the media
are actively concealing the heinous
actions of these fringe groups because
they serve their ends no matter the
tactic no matter the violence or mayhem
these groups are largely given a pass
because they are brazenly vociferously
consistently vitriolic ly resisting
Trump
how ironic by the way is that that just
days ago the Boston Globe convinced more
than a hundred news organizations to
blast the president for his verbal and
written attacks on the media it's not
collusion or anything well they're set
to release coordinated editorials and
newspapers across the country later this
week yet when a group or groups actively
attack them the press were physically
destroying their equipment they scream
vile things and threaten reporters the
media silence is deafening it's Fox News
who's who's supporting the protection of
journalists I suppose the old saying is
true the enemy of my enemy is my friend
no matter how awful and violent that
friend may be but if they continue to
turn a blind eye to the hateful actions
of groups like Ann Tifa while
exaggerating the importance of a handful
of goofy races craving attention the
question must be
who's really fomenting division in
America the guy whose policies brought
black and Hispanic unemployment to
record lows who fights to keep ms-13 out
of already stressed areas I don't think
so
I think America is a lot smarter than
the media think they are and I think
they see what real hate is and who's
trying to solve
rather than stoke problems and that's
the angle